so the first case of coronavirus
globally that we know of confirmed was
January 10 the first case in the United
States was January 20
we now have well over a hundred thousand
cases heading very quickly to two
hundred thousand cases it's been months
since this started and Donald Trump
still doesn't appear to know what
coronavirus is which is of course a
virus Oh Donald Trump's almost daily
Gong Show press briefings have been
truly houses of Horrors I've been
covering and live fact fact-checking
most of them I took like a mental health
break over the weekend but I did get
this one moment sent to me from the
Friday one that I have to show you which
is Donald Trump again in the wave that
only Donald Trump can talking about
something he doesn't know about like no
one knows about it when in reality he's
almost the only person left who doesn't
understand these basic things about the
virus here is Trump saying is this a
germ is it a flu is it a virus no one
really knows what it is pandemic by this
disease this whatever they want to call
you've got it germ you can call it a flu
you can call it a virus you can call it
many different names I'm not sure
anybody even knows what it is is this
ringing an alarm to anyone else we're
months into this and Trump is saying
things like they don't really know what
this is
you could also I guess call it the
Chinese virus which Donald Trump notably
has stopped saying clearly somebody got
to him and said that's enough with the
Chinese virus stuff how bad is this
guy's is that the germ flu or virus no
one knows it's almost April this has
been around since January 10 with
confirmed cases Trump was briefed on it
in December this isn't funny anymore as
if it ever was it's a type of corona
virus this is a virus it's not the flu
it causes respiratory illness it spreads
through contact with infected people
when they cough or sneeze or through
contaminated surfaces coronavirus has
been around for a long time we've known
about them a long time it's not the flu
the death rate is higher the spread
ability is higher more people are dying
daily every day that we go but we have
an increased death toll from this and
Trump is lecturing about they don't even
know what it is we know you're just not
doing what needs to be done to fix it by
and large if Trump had said on December
30th
is it a germ flu or virus no one knows
you know I'd probably say hey he's at
least talking about it instead of
ignoring it to save this on March what
was the 27th or 28th when he said this
whenever it occurred over the weekend
this is truly the stuff of Horrors and
the only thing you know I I am NOT
someone who looks to criticize Trump for
everything he does when it doesn't
deserve criticism Trump made the right
decision not to open things up on Easter
again based on what he said yesterday it
may change by tomorrow Donald Trump said
were extending social distancing
guidelines until April 30th that's the
right decision now had this been started
earlier we might be looking at being
able to release some of those guidelines
earlier doesn't be that as it may this
is where we are and the right decision
today is that obviously we're not ready
to lift these guidelines in a few days
we're gonna have to go until April 30th
that's the right decision Trump
continuing to say things like is this
the germ is it a flu no one really knows
what it is is weaponized ignorant
problematic to the nth degree and it's
leading to Donald from continuing to
avoid blame and responsibility in any
way possible as I said earlier Donald
Trump implying or suggesting you know
maybe the reason we have a mask shortage
isn't because he failed but because
masks are being stolen by hospitals he's
going to continue doing this stuff and
in fact we now have more information
about why we have such a shortage and
it's not because of Obama let me tell
you that and I want to address that next
I've got something really cool today the
first 500 people who see this video and
go to david pakman.com slash skill will
get a premium membership to Skillshare
for two
for free skill shares the online
learning community offering thousands of
classes on almost anything you can
imagine
everything's taught by experts the
classes get split up into bite-size
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me you can fit Skillshare into your
schedule there are classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design running a small business and
that's not even scratching the surface I
got some great ideas from a recent class
I took called YouTube success and even
though we've been on YouTube for years I
still got a lot out of it they have
classes for every skill level whether
you want to get better at something
you're already experienced in or you
want to explore something totally new
and like I said the first 500 people who
see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
completely free premium membership for
two months giving you access to every
class Skillshare offers check it out I
put the link right underneath this video